temple du bas
[Musique]
à
les séjours
m
à
[Musique]
c'est un cas
m
[Musique]
ah oui
il
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
k
[Musique]
et
oh
3 combien
[Musique]
moi
même première
c'est donc une partie salon thani pas
comparer
othello division c'est toujours un
serment aux parfums vanille au paradis
et puis un jour doublement yoka camp
l'alluré
balmont
dix ans
et
[Musique]
c'est vrai
lamballe
[Musique]
quand
hahaha
cette île à m
ces fonds
voir
sow
ouf c'est fou ça
[Musique]
ces programmes ont passé
en soirée
qui
[Musique]
s'inquiète et nouilles en belgique
c'était la crème à la vanille
il aime les touches france ici n'a pas
même pas que c'était des lieux
[Musique]
et puis la crise est là mais l'avenir
il faut passer
jouer mais en même temps
jamais là
[Musique]
à